donc
[Applaudissements]
l'autre jour j'attendais le bus en bas
de chez moi pour aller au boulot j'étais
seul perdu dans mes pensées quand j'ai
entendu le bus arrive et je me suis levé
je me suis rapproché du bord de la route
et j'ai levé la main pour signaler au
chauffeur que j'étais partante pour
embarquer c'est là que j'ai vu passer un
camion toupie bon point il s'est pas
arrêté il m'a planté là toute seule avec
ma dignité
peut-être pensez-vous que c'est une
fille étourdis ou bien que j'étais saoul
complètement bourré mais en réalité chez
malvoyantes vraiment mal voyante depuis
mon adolescence je suis atteinte d'un
trouble de la vision centrale
donc en pratique quand vous regardez ce
petit homme et ben moi je le vois comme
ça je n'ai pas de problème pour voir les
grands ensembles pour me déplacer
mais la vision de détails c'est pas
terrible ça m'empêche de caractériser
précisément l'objet roulant
si l'état plus de quelques mètres la
lecture est aussi une activité compliqué
enfin sauf si la police est en 72 mais
là un roman devient vite légèrement
encombrants ce sont mes activités
professionnelles qui m'ont amené à me
questionner sur la place des
travailleurs handicapés dans une
organisation
a priori c'est pas gagné parce que le
taux de chômage des travailleurs
handicapés et le double de la population
moyenne ces recherches ont attisé ma
curiosité
je me suis renseigné formé sur le sujet
et là j'ai tiré sur des sujets en boîte
et les thèmes de la formation de
l'éducation de l'accès aux bâtiments à
l'espace public et je vais m'arrêter là
parce que sinon ça risque d'être un peu
long mais tous ces thèmes se sont
dévoilés et franchement
c'est à se demander c'est la société qui
les cachent ou c'est les personnes
handicapées qui se planque
et ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on retrouve
les personnes handicapées
bien trop souvent à part ce constat m'a
personnellement interrogé je veux dire
comment ça se fait que j'ai réussi à
déjouer les statistiques
non parce que moi j'ai fait des études
que j'ai choisie en plus je vis en
couple
je suis maman j'ai créé mon entreprise
enfin franchement il apparaît que
j'appartiens la vie ordinaire
certains diront que c'est grâce à mon
caractère
genre un peu tu nas c'est pas faux mais
cette seule explication apparaît un peu
courte
du coup j'en rajouterai trois autres la
première c'est que mon handicap est
quasi invisible
je voulais dit je vois l'essentiel et
pour les détails j'utilise des moyens de
compensation mon ordinateur est
formidable il me lit tout et l'option
appareil photo de mon téléphone portable
me permet de zoomer tout partout et en
toute discrétion
je suis aussi de nombreuses stratégies
de contournement mon sourire ma mémoire
et ma capacité d'adaptation sont de
sacrés atouts
je développe pas mais c'est une fine
organisation et beaucoup d'astuces pour
contourner les difficultés que je
rencontre au quotidien
la deuxième chose qui me paraît
importante c'est que je n'ai jamais eu
peur du mot handicap
je revendique même une certaine fierté
d'appartenir à cette communauté
car au plus loin où remontent mes
souvenirs j'ai toujours eu des amis en
situation de handicap et je me suis
senti en riches à leur contact
enfin la troisième chose fondamentale
c'est que mes proches m'ont toujours
encouragé parfois au détriment de leurs
propres peurs d'ailleurs leur présence
rassurante m'a permis de rester sourd
aux injonctions limitantes du style bof
fait pas d'études un toute manière
personne ne voudrait embaucher
aujourd'hui je vis mon handicap non pas
comme une limite
mais comme une opportunité une
opportunité de développer ma sensibilité
ma créativité
ma vision différente du monde c'est
d'ailleurs grâce à cela je suis là
devant vous que je suis consultante en
développement durable est également
formatrice en pratique inclusive une
société inclusive et le pilier social
incontournable d'un développement
durable il s'agit là d'une société qui
permet la participation de tous qui
s'adapte qui s'enrichit des différences
qui lutte contre les exclusions et les
discriminations
alors je voulais vous donner ma petite
recette d'une société inclusive
j'accentue ray cependant mon propos sur
le handicap certes parce que je suis
concernée mais également parce que cette
année encore pour son dernier mandat
le défenseur des droits de la république
jacques toubon a confirmé que le
handicap est le premier critère de
discrimination ce avant la couleur de
peau le genre ou l'orientation sexuelle
alors c'est parti
prenez un handicap vous avez le choix
peut-être instinctivement opterez-vous
pour un handicap physique sensoriel ou
intellectuel mais le champ du handicap
et plus larges sont concernés également
les personnes porteuses d'un handicap
psychique d'une maladie invalidante ou
d'un polyhandicap version la plus lourde
mais pas la moins intéressante
bon je vais pas me lancer dans un
listing exhaustif qui répond à
l'exercice de catégorisation
administrative 1
je pense qu'il ya 400 personnes qui me
remercient
j'ai plutôt choisi de vous faire toucher
du doigt l'importante diversité des
situations de handicap
maintenant que vous avez choisi accordez
vous un peu de temps pour comprendre les
déficiences qui lui sont associés je
parle ici des difficultés quotidiennes
que rencontrent ces personnes il y a
plein de ressources merveilleuse et très
ludique sur internet
mais le must est de questionner
quelqu'un qui le vit juste à ce stade
attention de ne pas vous laisser gagner
par la pitié elle ne construit rien de
durable ou par la condescendance
elle nourrit la colère alors on peut
continuer d'observer maintenant les
stratégies de contournement que cette
personne met en place pour avancer dans
la vie l'an passé j'ai animé une session
de formation je devais préparer des
demandeurs d'emploi à aborder leur
handicap dans un entretien d'embauché
dans cette session tonio technicien en
bâtiment présentait des troubles de la
mémoire accentuée par un traitement anti
épileptiques
il avait du mal à retenir toutes les
astuces que je donnais à l'oral alors il
écrivait tout dans son cahier
méthodiquement et très soigneusement
au delà de sa motivation j'ai été frappé
par son savoir être ultra agréable et en
détaillant son cv j'ai noté sa quinzaine
d'années d'expérience passées dans
plusieurs grandes entreprises de la
place je pensait tenir là une belle
piste d'optimisme pour les autres
stagiaires
alors j'ai demandé de nous raconter
comment il avait réussi à concilier son
handicap et sa vie professionnelle il
s'est trouvé un peu emprunté il nous a
répondu
en fait j'ai jamais dis à tous mes
collègues tous mes patrons que j'avais
une reconnaissance de handicap parce
qu'à chaque fois que je les dis dans un
entretien d'embauché
on m'a jamais recruté alors toutes ces
années bah j'ai rien dit j'ai feinté
personne ne le sait
j'avoue là il m'a scié je m'attendais
pas vraiment à cette réponse
alors j'ai demandé de nous raconter
comment il avait fait en fait qu antonio
prend un poste
il se concentre à fond et il note tout
dans un petit cahier ce qu'il doit faire
l'enchaînement des opérations les
informations particulières les horaires
et garde toujours son cahier sur lui
comme ça s'il a un trou il se met
discrètement dans un coin reprend ses
notes et là il se rappelle quelques
semaines plus tard je croise une copine
qui bossait dans la dernière entreprise
autonome était en poste et parce que je
suis curieuse et que j'avais vraiment
saisi le contexte de son départ je lui
ai demandé de m'expliquer pourquoi
l'entreprise avait remercié
elle m'a raconté ah oui on lui a fait un
licenciement économique on n'avait plus
de contrat dans son secteur et puis lui
il avait d'autres projets mais je me
fais pas de souci pour lui c'est un gars
super un employé en or ultra performant
elle a marqué une pause mais regardez
que des grands yeux tout ronds et elle a
rajouté
mais comment tu le connais il est
handicapé lui est ce que vous l'avez là
la puissance des stratégies de
contournement
elle ouvre le champ des possibles est
franchement donnio n'est pas un cas
isolé
il suffit juste d'accepter de se laisser
surprendre normalement à ce stade de
l'exposer on est bon sur le changement
de regard et c'est bien là l'essentiel
mais au delà des prises de conscience
une société inclusive a besoin de la
mobilisation de toutes nos compétences
les chantiers sont nombreux l'enjeu est
de taille mais les bénéfices profiteront
à tous oui tous car nous vivront chacun
en moyenne 8 ans de notre vie en
situation de handicap et dans 80 % des
cas
ce handicap sera invisible alors il ya
du boulot pour tout le monde
parmi vous il y a ceux qui pourront
s'imprégner des principes de
l'accessibilité universelle
ceux qui pourront s'engager dans la voie
du management de la diversité du
management par les compétences certains
pourront adapter leur communication
grâce à la méthode facile à lire et à
comprendre et d'autres encore
par exemple pourront porter leurs
efforts sur une approche positive de la
différence bref quoiqu'il en soit garder
toujours en tête cette diversité des
handicaps cette attention particulière à
avoir
cette palette incroyable de solutions
humaines et techniques
cette adaptation souvent mineurs qui
facilitera la participation de tous
c'est là que vous serez acteur d'une
société inclusive
merci
[Applaudissements]